of course I would say we don't have
enough power you know the labor movement
has changed dramatically 1973 25% of the
private sector workforce was unionized
we're down to below seven percent
overall including the public sector
we're at twelve percent that being said
the labor movement still has an
incredibly powerful place in both
national and state politics because we
are well organized force we participate
in the political process at a much much
higher rate than the regular public and
at a higher rate than most other
organized groups and we put people out
on the street on Election Day and that
matters because our members vote and we
can make change that being said the
attack by corporate America on unions
specifically since the 70s through today
has been extraordinary you know a lot of
the discussion about what's happened to
the labor movement and why's it shrink
you know people talk about globalization
and technological change but the reality
is that the attack by corporate America
on the right to organize it has been a
much much more powerful force in terms
of shrinking the size of the movement
and a lot of the focus of the labor
movement nationally now is on achieving
federal legislation the employee free
choice act that would at least put a
dent in prohibiting companies and
employers from illegally intimidating
and attacking workers that want to
organize